is why we're here I was gonna say I love
the family affair of it all tonight I
mean if I'm being very honest with you
we had gone to the Little Mermaid
Premiere a few you know what is it was
it last week
and he was like so jealous so I was like
okay fine we'll come here and this is
like his favorite right yeah yeah he
loves this
doctor yeah I also play it on a PS5
the game and I beat the game twice
so yeah yeah but it's really nice to
like bring my son here his birthday was
what June 28th he'll be 12.
go big happy birthday thank you see you
later yeah I have to say I play the PS5
game two I'm replaying it right now
times I just don't do any missions I
just swing through the city for like an
hour and a half I stink at those games I
don't even try I'm sorry you have to
have you ever tried playing no he tries
to get me to play with him all the time
but I'm like used to the what is it like
the Mario Super Mario I'm like you know
I'm old
what are you most looking forward to
about tonight
I personally just spending quality time
with my son just to get that time in
um it means a lot to me and this is
definitely one of his favorite you know
uh characters out of the whole Marvel
you know Heroes and so I'm like anything
for you right yeah what do you love
about Miles Morales uh I love that like
he's like really powerful you know and
yeah and like how like the effects and
like the movie when it says like boom
all that stuff do you want to tell him
the story of when you met him yeah
we went to the Spider-Man no way home
Premiere and he was sitting right behind
me and I didn't even know he didn't know
a person had asked you who is your
favorite out of all the the heroes and I
said Morales and then he was in front of
us and he yes and he turned around and
he was like oh thanks bro thanks bro so
oh my God what is it the cool mom
points or Awards you know for that for
that night so hopefully I get some
points for tonight too right yeah I mean
you already have so
[Laughter]
thank you bye
[Music]
foreign